they write one scientific paper on the subject.
And out of that field campaign we'll probably get a few dozen papers
on a few dozen processes or molecules.
As a body of knowledge builds up, it will form one subsection,
or one sub-subsection,
of an assessment like the IPCC, although we have others.
And each one of the 11 chapters of the IPCC has six to ten subsections.
So you can imagine the scale of the effort.
In each one of the assessments we write, we always tag on a summary,
and the summary is written for a non-scientific audience.
And we hand that summary to journalists and policy makers
in order to make headlines like these.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)